par année ce sont des rescapés de
l'enfer
kim et lee ont survécu aux camps de
travail de la corée du nord
ils y ont vu la mort la souffrance la
cruauté et le mal incarné les gardes
nous cracher leurs sécrétions dans la
bouche souvient kim
si on avait le hall coeur ils nous
battaient jusqu'à la mort un jour j'ai
vu un prisonnier tenté de s'échapper
raconte lee il a été rattrapé puis
ramenés au camp traîner derrière une
voiture pendant des kilomètres
ensuite ils l'ont exécuté selon l'onu il
y aurait actuellement jusqu'à 200 mille
prisonniers politiques dans ces camps le
rapport du conseil des droits de l'homme
de l'onu accuse le régime nord coréen de
crimes contre l'humanité et réclamé une
enquête de la cour pénale internationale
kim jong-un devra répondre de ces
atrocités prévient l'auteur du rapport
parmi les crimes reprochés au régime
nord-coréen la torture les viols les
esclavages l'enlèvement les exécutions
sommaires et l'extermination les
prisonniers qui ne perdent pas la raison
se transforme en véritable bête se
rappelle lits seront rois de 11 ans
maintenant qu on avait tellement rien à
manger qu'on récupère lé grains de maïs
dans les excréments des vaches pour ne
pas mourir de faim l'horreur de ces
camps est telle qu elle suffit à
maintenir le régime en place soutient ce
colis six nord-coréens qui tient à
garder l'anonymat pour l'école de
travail les gens savent que s'ils se
révoltent ce n'est pas seulement leur
vie qui sera détruite mais aussi celle
de toute leur famille
c'est ce qui est arrivé à kim parce que
son grand père aurait fui vers la corée
du sud
c'est toute sa famille qui a été
internés dans des camps elle ya passé 28
ans avant de réussir à s'enfuir
aujourd'hui elle dessine pour tenter
d'oublier lice villeneuve radio canada
montréal